oh
[Musique]
à
je suis raphaël et pour la plus grande
partie de ma vie j'ai couru contre la
montre mais récemment tout a changé
et je vais vous raconter pourquoi et
comment
j'ai grandi dans une famille où les
hautes études de préférence scientifique
c'était une évidence tacite c'était
fondamental
mon père est x mais deux grands frères
sont ingénieurs et très tôt ma mère
était persuadé que je le serai aussi et
puis d'un autre côté dans la famille
avait une culture il y avait du cinéma
de la musique du piano du chant de la
danse
émoi dans tout ça
j'étais et je suis toujours ce qu'on
appelle hypersensible et entre autre
chose ça veut dire que j'avais besoin
d'énormément d'amour et de sécurité
et c'est comme ça que ma première course
a commencé
j'ai cru que pour pouvoir obtenir cet
amour et cette sécurité il fallait que
je devienne cette poupée parfaite que
mes parents attendaient de moi
alors j'ai été parfaite j'étais
excellente à l'école à chaque fois que
je suis une représentation artistique
c'était imperfections je rangeais ma
chambre j'étais jolie poli je disais pas
de bêtises et puis il ya un mal être
profond qui a commencé à grandir en moi
mais moi j'avais juste l'impression que
sam indiqué que j'étais pas assez
parfaite qu'il fallait que je fournisse
plus d'efforts alors jean tournée c'est
et on va célébrer pour ça
et puis juste après le bac j'ai fait un
stage de comédie pâle pendant l'été à
londres et des professionnels m'ont dit
que j'étais fait pour chanter et danser
et jouer la comédie
mais quand je suis rentré à paris
mes parents tantes et autrement et il
était impossible pour moi de ne pas
faire ce que eux qui voulait le meilleur
pour moi
avait choisi
alors je fais prépare et puis j'ai eu à
centrale paris et puis ensuite j'ai fait
architecturaux polytechnique de milan
et le mal être grandissant et
grandissait
c'est que à 25 ans une fois bardé de
diplômes qu'un poids s'est soulevée de
mes épaules et j'ai enfin compris ma
première leçon de vie
c'est moi qui choisis ce que je fais
dans la vie
je me souviendrai toujours la première
fois que j'ai vu billy elliot
j'ai eu une révélation quand j'ai vu la
grand mère qui ne cesse de répéter tout
courbet dans sa chaise
ait bengrir ballerines
il était hors de question que je
devienne cette grand mère
je savais que j'adorais le cinéma et la
comédie musicale
par contre je savais pas si j'avais le
talent pur je savais pas si j'étais
petit j'avais l'impression de trahir mes
parents et de
snober avec un rock ans le grand rêve
français
cette fois ci je le ferai c'était
impossible que je vis pas mes rêves
alors je vais penser et ma deuxième
course a commencé
j'ai appelé ça reste un accélérateur
parce que j'avais pris part perdu trop
de temps
alors je suis allé voir toute l'équipe
de comédie musicale j'ai attendu les
artistes j'ai travaillé de ma voix j'ai
travaillé des chorégraphies j'ai appris
j'ai pris des cours de théâtre g
j'ai tout fait et en un an on a proposé
trois rôles
et après l'école sont enchaînés et en
quatre ans j'ai même réalisé deux de mes
plus grands rêves j'étais devenu le
premier rôle dans le théâtre parisien de
comédies musicales de broadway moderne
une mise en scène par un immense
réalisateur et la même année je tourne
pour l'une des plus grandes productions
mondiales de films
je m'émerveillais des miracles qui se
passait devant mes yeux
mais voilà le mal être dont je parlais
même s'il avait disparu pendant un temps
mais il est en train de revenir
j'étais plus très heureuse même sur
scène
en fait j'avais compris que même si le
décor avait changé l'histoire restée la
même c'était plus à mes parents que je
devais plaire c'était au jury d'audition
au réalisateur au public aux collègues
il fallait que je trouve ma place pour
pouvoir avoir cet amour et cette
sécurité mais j'arrivais pas à la
trouver il fallait que je devienne ce
que vous voulez
mais ça se passait pas
alors
à ce moment là j'ai compris qu'ils
avaient quelque chose de bien plus
existentielles qui se passait il
s'agissait de
trouver la liberté d'être soi mais
comment on fait pour trouver le droit
d'être soi quand on sait même pas qui
c'est soit
ce qui m'a sauvé c'est que mon système
nerveux s'est épuisé
et alors là je comprenais plus rien
j'avais plus de force et une vague de
désespoir a commencé à s'abattre sur moi
alors j'ai
j'ai fait comme on peut essayer de
d'avoir plus d'accomplissement tu aller
à londres thual à los angeles j'ai
tourné des films et
un an moment j'avais juste plus
d'énergie
donc j'ai décidé de laisser la vague me
submerger
et c'est là que tout a changé
c'est dans ce lâcher prise que j'ai
réalisé qu'ils avaient un programme qui
avait régis mon cerveau toute ma vie et
il disait
je suis fondamentalement inadéquate je
n'ai absolument pas de valeur
je ne vaux rien et les gens qui me
connaissent ils me connaissaient
vraiment in détesterait et il faut
absolument que je cache tout ça par des
accomplissements et une image parfaite
que je renvoie
le moment où j'ai pris conscience de
cette croyance
mais je me suis rendu compte que j'avais
le droit de ne pas y croire
et c'est là que j'ai compris ma deuxième
leçon crucial de ma vie
c'est moi qui choisis ma vérité
c'est moi qui choisis mes croyances
à partir de là j'ai décidé que je
pouvais plus avancer la même façon il
fallait que je trouve cet amour et cette
sécurité à l'intérieur de moi et que je
décide moi-même maintenant de ce que
j'allais faire pas faire ce que
j'attends depuis que les gens
attendaient de moi
j'allais écouter mon intuition
j'étais entré en chrysalide ça a
expliqué l'épuisement et le noir
la ligne droite est déterminé
rationnelle et est en train de devenir
une spirale intuitif qui promettait le
sublime
j'allais devenir papillon
mais comment
par le mystère de l'alchimie
c'est précisément dans cette noirceur
que j'ai découvert ma valeur
c'est dans le plomb que j'ai trouvé l'or
en fait quand on y pense ça a du sens
c'est que quand on va voir le plus
sombre en soit ce qui nous dégoûte ce
qui nous rend honteux ce qui nous
culpabiliser et qu'on se rend compte
qu'on est toujours là
que tout ça c'est des enfants intérieur
terroriser et qu'on peut les aimer tels
qu'ils sont
qu'on peut dire qu'on s'aime vraiment
parce qu'on aime même ça
c'est ça l'amour avec un grand a
alors à partir de là j'ai
j'ai été aidé par des personnes
spécialisées et dans plein de modalités
différentes mais notamment l'expérience
somatique
j'ai appris à être présente à moi même
j'ai compris déjà peu plus je fuis ces
ombres plus elle me suivent
et que ce côté obscur c'est mon allié
parce que il me guide vers la seule
chose qui me libère la présence à moi
et petit à petit dans mon corps les
choses se reprogrammer il a commencé à
faire bon vivre dedans parce que j'étais
présente à cet inconfort avec curiosité
et avec fascination
j'ai compris que la perfection en fait
elle avait toujours été là et elle
s'appelle le moment présent
et que quand j'arrive pas à accepter
accueillir ce moment présent tel qu'il
est ça veut dire qu'une croyance qu'il
ya un moment dans mon passé ou le futur
imaginaire qui sont mieux que cet
instant
mais il n'existe que cet instant
et d'ailleurs si on n'était pas là pour
le percevoir
est-ce qu'il existerait
il n'existe que notre perception du
moment présent
le monde que je vois
n'existe que par le fait que je le
perçois
exactement comme un appareil de mesure
quantique qui détermine l'état d'une
particule par le fait qu'ils observent
au moment où ils l'observent
mais on est d'accord que la perception
elle est complètement dépendante de nos
croyances de nos notre éducation notre
façon unique de voir le monde me cinq
sens
donc si le monde n'existe que par le
fait que je le perçois il ne peut que me
refléter mes croyances intérieur
comme un miroir
j'ai alors compris que
c'est ça le libre arbitre c'est qu'on
peut choisir comment on perçoit le monde
on peut soit le résister soit
l'accueillir exactement tel qu'il est
et que gandhi c'est peut-être ça qui
voulait dire quand il disait soyez le
changement que vous voulez voir dans le
monde parce que si on change notre façon
de percevoir on change le monde quand
voit donc le monde le celles qui
existent
à partir de là j'ai décidé que
j'accepterai le moment présent comme un
présent comme un cadeau et le moment
présent a commencé à devenir un cadeau
fractal
d'ailleurs une idée on a deux façons de
voir le monde soit comme si rien n'était
un miracle ça comme si tout était un
miracle et je préfère nettement la
deuxième
mais moi aussi je préfère nettement la
deuxième à vous
depuis que je vis comme ça
il ya énormément de choses dans ma vie
qui se sont changés lorsque ça
s'applique à toutes les dimensions de ce
que ça veut dire d'être un être humain
notamment au niveau de ma santé j'avais
des allergies de l'asthme des cycles
complètement irrégulier et tous et
rééquilibrer
la relation aux autres s'est
complètement transformé mon art est
devenu plus authentique plus puissant
j'ai compris qu'on incarnant ma vérité
j'autorise à l'autre d'incarner la
sienne et qu'on peut se rendre plus
puissants les uns les autres comme ça je
suis passé du monde du devoir au monde
du pouvoir pouvoir dans le sens je peux
j'en suis capable
et je peux ne pas le faire si j'en ai
pas envie
d'ailleurs quand on sent qu'on doit
faire quelque chose ça veut dire qu'on
est en train de donner de renoncer à
notre pouvoir de choisir comment on
perçoit le moment présent
on décide qu'il est inacceptable tel
qu'il est
et qu'il faut le changer
et parfois je vous concède que c'est
très difficile d'accepter le moment
présent tel qu'il est
mais dans ce monde de contrastes
les moments difficiles sont tout aussi
riche que les moments joyeux
et c'est ça le pouvoir de l'alchimie
c'est ça la beauté de notre univers
le côté obscur mène à la présence
l'unique chose qui nous libère
il existe une fissure dans toute chose
c'est par là que la lumière passe 10 et
leonard cohen
nous vivons dans un film 3d immersif que
nous sommes en train de créer
en le percevant et plus on sera en
harmonie avec ce savoir plus le monde
sera harmonieux parce que
on saura notre puissance
on n'aura plus besoin domine l'autre
pour devenir
aimé puisse en être en sécurité
on saura qu'on largue l'intérieur
j'ai notamment découvert ces dernières
années
la puissance de l'alchimie par le son
est notamment par le son de la voix
humaine et je vous invite si vous le
voulez bien à me rejoindre dans un
moment alchimique où on va chanter
ensemble
je vous invite à fermer les yeux
et à sentir vos pieds
sur le sol
et à sentir votre corps sur votre chaise
dans ce moment
juste ce moment
de sentir votre respiration à
l'intérieur de votre corps sans la
changer elle vous masse intérieurement
et dans un instant
je vais chanter une note et je vais vous
inviter à me rejoindre en harmonisant
avec vous pouvez chanter la même note
pouvait argenté une autre celle qui vous
plaît y'a aucune fausse note
et observer ce que ça fait dans votre
corps
bon
[Musique]
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux
merci d'avoir co créer une scène du film
avec moi
[Applaudissements]